the music fest was really a look at  celeb couples after breakup check out  Katy Perry this girl's all about  spending some time with her squad crop  tops by the pool and working out hard  Katy showed off her revenge body dressed  all in white at her shoe lines Easter  Sunday recovery bro  [Music]  meanwhile her ex Orlando Bloom was also  at Coachella his MO where a try to go  incognito hoodie with wingman Leonardo  DiCaprio as rumors circle that he's  hooking up with vampire diaries star  nina dobrev but source close to Nina  tells us they are quote just friends  they have the same manager and have  known each other for a long time there  is nothing romantic going on between the  two but the real winner of Coachella was  headliner lady gaga she performed her  new single the Cure and film new scenes  with Bradley Cooper for their upcoming  film a stars for gaga posed of this  first look and we love it  [Music]